so joe rogan uh um uh uh the joe rogan
show was canceled all shows canceled
this week you're supposed to have kanye
west on because joe rogan's producer
jamie
got covered hope you're doing well uh
probably at a tim dillon show
probably at a tim dylan show but here's
the ready for a little conspiracy cuties
meets weapon in the morning
i don't believe for a second that jamie
even got covered
okay he could have maybe gone covered
because look he's got a lot of money now
they're in texas he was probably a nerdy
kid growing up he doesn't know how to
deal with women so he might be out
trying to get puss just because
you know it's just all new and i
understand that it's the same reason why
louis jerked off in a plant it's just
you know when you don't grow up as a
teenager knowing how to talk to girls
and all of a sudden they come at you
it's tough so that could be one
explanation but the second thing which i
think is the more true thing i don't
think jamie has coven i don't think
anybody has cole but i think spotify put
pressure on rogan
to make something up to cancel all the
shows because they know if they
interview kanye on friday and they give
a good interview
that's going to sway votes away from
biden of course it will because by then
nobody wants to vote for that guy
so so it's going to sway votes and
they'll go to kanye which would of
course put trump in the presidency so i
think the conspiracy here
is that spotify and all those places put
pressure on rogan and it's election
meddling and they do not want
rogan because rogan can very easily just
get another producer for a week or
zoom uh kanye west in and get the thing
up on friday to cancel them all
it's got [ __ ] democrat [ __ ]
written all over to me
and it's simply because they know for a
fact a lot of people are scared
because a lot of people are on epstein's
island a lot of people on that travel
log
joe biden's pedophile do what's right
november
[Laughter]
wow that's my freddy's name is patty
boroni my name's sean tyree with a
couple firefighters who read the new
york post
every single [ __ ] night is what it is
yeah it's a little thing called ladder
faulty
it's what it is because now what do you
think of that is that a little on the
nose
i think that's what you call a little of
the nose i mean you [ __ ] nailed it my
mind was blown the whole time
because the thing about me and you is
we're figuring out everything
yeah it's just what it is unfortunately
we're figuring it out i mean what can
you do homeless pimp you're gonna have
to clip that and we're gonna post it
[Music]